hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm
John Humphrey your that's your line
haven't you got improv
come on play along no but nobody it was
like a paradoxical improv well hey for a
while now people have been saying -
check this video out Ronald McDonald
versus Cookie Monster from raka raka
julie's on has never seen a rack a rack
of video I tried giving her an
explanation of what raka raka is didn't
go well we don't have a gun no my first
McDonald's was built like a year I love
oh yeah what a Chinese burger tastes
like probably like a regular today's
patron in the day shoutout Kent McKnight
he's from Australia John - your
Australian accent he's from Australia
can't mcnaught we're gonna give you a
shout out shout out after the reaction
die after the reaction let's watch rock
Iraq a trauma divers Cookie Monster
previously on lost
[Music]
oh my god what
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[ __ ] homo
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wait what dude Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] two days and doesn't let chit
Rob what are you going
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm so impressed by the action in this
hold
oh damn you internet minute a minute to
go it's always that the most exciting
part
all right guys finally got internet back
let me make sure Mike's on ok good let's
go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's gonna be a week old and just a
second okay Wow
we did all that all that time you're in
the Internet back up Wow for the most
shocking part of the video right there
was worth getting right back up well
Julie I know that's a strange thing to
be introduced to we have no prior
context or prior videos seeing yet what
are your first impressions of the rack
Iraq ah man I want them to be my
boyfriend I just watch but then I have
to say the action was really impressive
that was super well I could show you
some older videos were there like the
action scenes are [ __ ] batshit insane
like I threw out train I've met the two
main brothers like there's the like the
guy plays Ronald McDonald he's one of
the main brothers who runs this channel
they said they have no stuntman training
they just like learn [ __ ] on their own
they're just durable yeah they're kind
of like YouTube's version of Jackass but
it also does like pretty high-quality
sketch yeah yeah they're pretty awesome
though they are they are awesome it's
nice seeing Romney I know you had
already been part of the wreck of record
journey I've been watching these guys
for a while now and has nice scene
Ronald McDonald returned we've been
waiting for them to waiting for Ronald
McDonald to return and it's kind of
funny seeing him return in this format
because normally he's like the
antagonist type of character in the
sketches yeah
and now he's the one who's being ganged
up on and here we have we want him to
conquer and win at the end of the day
and I kind of feel like because of all
the changes with YouTube was this guy's
got pretty violent but they used to be
way more violent oh they used to be ways
yeah like with major breasts
oh the gore I don't know maybe like
they'll continue doing that down the
road but I know with YouTube's
guidelines like they block a lot more
videos now yes so I'm kind of wondering
like did they want to go even gory but
they couldn't because I feel like they
could have gone gory because there's a
dress fast at least in a couple videos
where they're like I believe they
describe them as a bunch of [ __ ] now
yeah and that's why the content hasn't
been as crazy lately even though I is
still pretty great surprise would you
prefer it more gory oh yeah I love I
like it I'm we can do their thing
unbridled because that's what you two
used to be about yeah the PSA hey yeah
now it's like what's clean everything so
that nobody who used to make a living
off of this now is homeless I still
really enjoyed the sketch it's it is
like man that they are so chaotic with
their vlog styles it's nuts and I liked
how they just include a Ronald McDonald
as part of the world this time yeah cuz
I know you haven't seen them before but
normally Ron McDonald it's like its own
separate thing and now they're putting a
part of just the regular crew guys and
he's just staying there with them right
now ever since they got this house
they've been putting up a lot more
videos than recently anyhow and they
have this weird loose style where like
the first half is just kind of their day
slash general destruction and then the
second half becomes like a defined
sketch of some time specified
destruction yeah I always wonder if they
just like have a stockpile of excess
furniture because in every video they
destroyed it right that glass that was
real glass I'm like how see are these
they're not that safe they get injured a
lot when I talked to them they said they
they get hurt often they just do a bunch
of crazy-ass stunts on their own like
they've literally those guys you just
learn to flip on their own oh yeah
no like action we don't have that they
don't have that they don't have
insurance they're working on like a
movie or a show or something like that
so I feel like now at least you know
like throwing him through that
plate-glass window I was like that might
be you know sugar glass or some things
they might have a couple more like film
a curry tricks yeah but yeah I get the
general sense that when it comes to just
banging each other around not so natural
and I don't have that gene in me it's
fun to watch it's fun to watch other
people yeah we Felisa gleefully suffer I
could see Julie being part of Iraq Iraq
a sketch I'm a jackass I'm gonna ask
like do girls watch this what's their
demo
I believe it's mainly guys yeah I'm
gonna guess males II it's 18 to 34 it's
a super bro centric type of vibe from
their channel but I feel like there are
plenty of girls out there who probably
really love what they do
I enjoyed it did you it was it was in
entertaining watch planned on um please
be my boy no more videos and I could see
how I would ya know I I saw the soul the
depths of their soul through this video
feel like I have to be slightly drunk or
on some sort of drug to fully enjoy this
though oh yeah yeah like I got a good
abilify or you know a zoloft pill -
really - really set the mood yeah you
know we're like tylenol or like a good
Tylenol like two pills is high five
ibuprofen yeah five and Robyn's really
this melon drowsy video
natural a cup of green tea hey guys you
can subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification bell - on Humphrey on
Twitter and Instagram patreon become a
patreon eject today do it
Julie's on - shut up and dance on
YouTube it's not just dance videos
although she is a pretty bomb dancer and
she can freakin fight this girl fight
scenes on her channel that are super bad
I'm telling like some real badass cakes
and [ __ ] I'm not lying about that dance
Jews you dance on Instagram and Twitter
where she's constantly looking like
herself
you know yep oh yeah and before this
video is done Kent McKnight can shout
out for you buddy
goodbye my oh wow it's like they're two
of us now yeah Australia in the room
yeah don't don't include that Crocodile
Dundee
Hugh Jackman Kent McKnight we got to
know him on the Google hangout he
recently did through our patreon the
dude is a really friendly chap he's
handsome he kind of looks like Andrew
Garfield meets Joseph gordon-levitt a
little bit of like domhnall gleeson in
there yeah Wow and a bit of like a John
Goodman personality kind of like a Rosie
O'Donnell sense of humor and an Amy
Schumer body type and a general like
just a Juris Elvis suaveness yeah this
is now a dating profile yeah yeah her
kids Oh Kent is actually single Ken -
the single Kent is single - yeah because
she goes to Australia often I think
you're the woman for the job perfect
well I see his email address on your
computer screen
he said he's specifically looking for an
Asian persuasion
suasion yes all right he says please be
Chinese I have a cousin in China